Ці маленькі дикі тварини з цінним хутром знову у центрі уваги. У норок виявили мутований коронавірус.
Повідомлення про це надійшли передусім з  Данії, яка є найбільшим у світі виробником норкового хутра.
У цій країні від норок, починаючи з червня, COVID-19 заразилися щонайменше 214 працівників ферм. Дванадцятеро з них - мутованим варіантом коронавірусу.
З огляду на ризик для населення глава уряду Данії наказала повністю знищити усе поголів'я тварин. А це понад 17 мільйонів норок.
Щоправда, зрештою парламент таку вимогу не підтримав. Адже наразі ВООЗ ще досліджує наслідки мутації для перебігу хвороби.
І все ж, мільйони тварин уже були вбиті. ОкрімДанії, SARS-CoV-2 на фермах з розведення норок знайшли також у США, Іспанії, Італії, Нідерландах і Швеції.
Через карантинні обмеження пройти на територію норкової ферми в Україні знімальній групі DW не дозволили.
Натомість директор підприємства на Київщині надав відео та розповів про роботу в часи пандемії.
У нас зараз 120 людей і жодного на лікарняному. Якби в нас хтось хворів повально...
Наприклад, приїхали і дізнались, що 20 людей на лікарняному, то явно тут є підозри.
У нас немає жодного на лікарняному. Ось в цьому питання. З цього треба починати.
За словами директора, на подібних звірофермах завжди були суворі заходи безпеки: до тварин допускаються лише ті, хто з ними безпосередньо працює.
Причому після спеціальної дезінфекції. Нині додався скринінг температури на вході та додаткове опитування працівників про стан здоров'я -
їх та членів їхніх родин. Загалом частка української хутрової продукції на світовому ринку становить лише 1%.
Це понад один мільйон норок на восьми українських звірофермах. Цих тварин на COVID-19 ніхто не перевіряв, так само не тестували і працівників звіроферм.
У Мініcтерстві охорони здоров'я лише оцінюють ймовірні ризики поширення хвороби від норок.
В Асоціації звірівників України DW заявили, що жодного випадку Сovid-19 на українських фермах не було, а власники завжди відкриті для перевірок.
Відповідні листи нібито вже надіслали урядовцям.
Наші листи прийняли. Але поки що нас не повідомляли про ті чи інші дії. Я так розумію, що поки що у нас основна увага зосереджена на дослідженнях ВООЗ.
Екоактивіст Павло Вишебаба дивується такій неквапливості чиновників.
Ми як ГО підшотвхуємо владу діяти швидко. У нас всього 8 ферм - це можна за один день сісти на машину і їх всі за один день об'їхати.
І зрозуміти, чи є хворі чи не має, взяти мазок у норок і перевірити.
Активіст критикує, що наразі уся інформація про ситуацію на фермах надходить лише від їхнього керівництва.
Він звертає увагу на те, що нині саме розпочався сезонний забій тварин, тож фермери зацікавлені будь-що успішно його завершити.
Звісно, що вони зацікавлена сторона. І що всі норки здорові, так само вони кажуть, що всі працівники здорові. І що вони не хворіли на коронавірус
під час пандемії. Хоча нашому ГО відомо щонайменше про два випадки захворювання працівників на хутряній фермі.
Невідомо, чи вони заразили норок, чи ще гірше - від норок.
Коронавірус у норок учергове підняв на поверхню питання про етичність хутрового бізнесу та його майбутнє в Україні.
Вже півтора року в екологічному комітеті Верховної Ради лежить закон про заборону хутрових ферм, який досі не розглянули.
Представники бізнесу заявляють, що руйнування звіроферм згубно вплине на села, куди вони сплачують немалі податки та де надають робочі місця.
Окрім того, норки, мовляв, з’їдають сотні тисяч тонн відходів від птахофабрик та рибної галузі.
Екоактивісти наполягають, що звіроферми натомість виробляють таку ж кількість відходів.
До того ж, їх потім нерідко незаконно викидають у водойми і на поля. Самих тварин все життя тримають в тісних клітках.
Є претензії і до способу знищення норок. Тим часом на українських фермах готуються не до закриття, а до можливого надприбутку.
Адже через повідомлення про масовий забій норок у Данії ціна на хутро на зовнішніх ринках вже підскочила на 20%.
Ми виграємо однозначно фінансово. Я думаю, що ми достатньо багато виграємо від цього.
Адже головний конкурент, який мав 50% світового виробництва - Данія - поступився.